of all the effects of the economic
crisis in Europe the one real scourge is
a youth unemployment some 5.6 million
young people aged between 15 and 24 were
jobless in the European Union in
September the unemployment rate for them
is more than twice that for adults in
Croatia Greece and Spain half of young
people are out of work that's why
European leaders have been taking
extraordinary steps to address this
urgent problem as demonstrated by the
recent Paris conference on youth
employment four main measures are being
taken to get young people out of
Europe's jobless queues the first is the
youth guarantee scheme aimed at ensuring
that all people under 25 receive a
quality offer of employment further
education or a traineeship within four
months of leaving school second the
youth employment initiative allows
funding from a 6 million euro total
budget for young people in regions where
jobless rates are more than twenty-five
percent third quality traineeships aimed
at easing the transition from education
to full-time employment and also an
effort to change public attitudes toward
apprenticeship style learning finally
encouraging young people to look for
work across Europe's borders in
neighboring states through labour
mobility programs like the US job
initiative the portal links uses to more
than 1.4 million job vacancies and over
300,000 registered employers these
measures are all part of Europe's
comprehensive program to tackle this
number one priority